this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen and a very warm welcome to you
again here on safari live we are on a
Sunday this afternoon and the
temperature is a beautiful 23 degrees
Celsius 84 degrees Fahrenheit is a
marvelous winter morning or afternoon
should I say it's been a beautiful day
and my name is Steve Falcon rich I'm
joined on camera by Craig and we are out
in drew Mesabi sands very excited honest
and I had the morning off I'm feeling
very very fresh after beautiful safari
labs episode last night I was just
showing you this little area here nice
open plains area and this is the area
that the cheetah family of the last week
came into and spent some time and
another elf Kirsten had them this
morning while from a distance I'm not
sure if you actually saw them but we
know kind of where they were hiding out
and we might be able to find them again
so there's our idea for this afternoon
to see if we can start with that so feel
free to Center your comments and
questions to hashtag Safari lab
alternates to be follow the YouTube
stream or whatever whatever other
platform you do prefer how has
everyone's weekend been in a marvelous
weekend the weather is so nice I've been
expecting some really cold weather as
June comes but so far last night was a
little bit chilly but once you get back
from Drive it's it's easy maybe it's
because I'm living in a house now been
living in a tent for the last three
years winters in a tent very cold
because that just gets colder and colder
through the night
Gregor you have lived in a tent in
winter no walls no heat so we're gonna
go up towards that our northern sort of
boundary bubbles hook boundary the sea
that's where the cheats were see this
morning around an area called Sydney's
dam we are on the western side of Juma
right now and it is kind of a nice open
area called sani patch sheets were plain
just here this is the kind of habitat
you expect them to find preferable
because they can see that's also it's
attracting game there's a fair bit of
vegetation to feed on also some animals
they want a bit of a sort of open area
to feed on such as wool the best and
zebra likes to come into these areas but
the cheats are looking for him parlor
but I'm not alone this afternoon in
Safari I'm joined also by a very nice
gentleman by the name of David hello and
good afternoon to all of you and welcome
to a sunrise sunset travel drive my name
is David and with me is fog excellent I
like the way he goes this fantastic I
have no plans for now I'm open to
anything that he'll see and this morning
I saw their sticks point of lions which
have been suffering from Manj but they
look much better
I've never seen them before but I was
told from were so and how they were
couple months ago they will pull it
through sometimes you usually think
mange when it comes it stands if it
wipes out afraid like that it's kind of
a nice way of you know balancing mother
nature and balancing the population of
some money music well either I'll go
looking for them or maybe my other
friend Rob will go do that but at the
moment I'm just open to see anything
that will come away the later parts
yesterday and today nothing nothing
doing not seen I'll be happy to see some
and remember most important as you might
be watching some nice a going by repair
we
request you to ask us as many questions
as you can please share with us your
thoughts and also send us some comments
as usual hashtag safari life you must
agree go away but think we're just
waiting for us Nia for me to start the
show no she is trying to swallow
something the other day I saw them
trying to spit or vomit some seeds as
now we have come to winter the only
eating the husks and then the hard part
of the seed they'll get it out so that's
the gray go away bad they'll always help
us sometimes when they make alum coughs
and you never know when they talk we
listen we follow sometimes you see
something and sometimes we don't
beautiful little bad start in a hot
afternoon here so we'll move on and we
are going also to make sure we have a
look on flag in every water pan that we
see because chances are someone could be
going for a drink
all right there could be bad screen for
drink could be Alice could be anybody
okay great temperatures a bit hot to the
sale of each one but again it's time to
look for animals under the sheets
what's warm like this maybe much later
on I'm going to cruise through the
Revati a time like now Ellie's would be
looking for big huge heads of trees that
will give them more shade the elephant's
don't like lots of heat especially if
they'll have the young ones so that's
also plan or an area thinking of
visiting much later today as it cools
off but at the moment is every water pan
we need to have a look remember we got
another young man by the name of ruff
well welcome aboard everybody and you
are now who with us here in Torchwood
Traverse I've just come across the
border from Juma and you are in the
greater Kruger National Park of South
Africa watching Safari live my name is
Ralph Kirsten looking straight into the
Sun on the camera is Davi Hauser Davi
now please don't forget to join us on
the hashtag Safari lava on Twitter and
on the YouTube live chat send us your
questions and your comments and join us
on the largest game Drive in the world
I'm just kind of turn away a little bit
because my eyes are directly in the Sun
day but we are going to be heading on to
Torchwood and I'm trying this afternoon
to try and catch up with the Torchwood
pride of lions as well as who knows
maybe we'll even catch up with Tandy and
play lumber it's a lovely warm afternoon
so expectations are that the Predators
maybe be a little bit flat for now but
that gives us a chance to get around
Torchwood and see what's going on maybe
we'll pick up some tracks and some other
little signs and who knows maybe we'll
even see some of those Raptors up in the
sky speaking of Raptors it seems Steve
has a really found one
yes we have found a very special Raptor
she very common in the savanna biome I
haven't seen one in some time now it
actually suggests this might be the
first one I've seen this year wonder how
many of you Raptor experts they are out
there you'll notice has got a very dark
eye the legs and sere if you're not
familiar with the word series that said
that sort of skin around the beak
joining onto the face so kind of a beak
and the skin joining the face it's
called the seer so the mouth really and
you see the legs of the same color and
he's doing a very characteristic thing
he's got one foot actually dangling
there at the moment as arrests it it's
quite characteristic of the species and
also the posture very straight back do
you see how a parotid stance
something snake eagles do there we go
and I was holding the leg rides up very
characteristic for the species of bird
and wonder how many of you out there
know what this is is you've seen it
before as I said is quite a common bird
in the savanna buyer but I haven't seen
one at some Tom hmm Grateful Dead it is
not a gym no gene a gym no gene yes does
have the potential to get a red face but
very very different Tajima gene is a
Harrier Hawk it's very big bird
yes it doesn't have feathers on the legs
like this bird but the German Aegean
bear in mind has got an entire sort of
skin pouch of a face whereas this is
just the beak
Nik you are an absolute champion you got
that spot on
now there's one bird that gets confused
with the Sun but is far smaller and
doesn't have as big a body size and
doesn't stand with that upright sort of
shape nick is guested correct I thought
it immediately when I saw it but you can
confuse it with the gaybar goshawk which
is a little bit smaller and coloration
of the legs and the sear are the same
but they do not stand with that upright
we can hear it call now who's calling
that's a contact call it's not the
actual call that it does it was just a
little cheep cheep I'm gonna actually
play the call for you and then we can
actually hear it a little contact call
they see if he responds to this call it
is in fact the dark chanting goshawk
ladies and gentlemen so if you got that
correct well done bear in mind remember
that very straight back and I listen I
went to play it on my phone see if it
responds are you gonna played once if we
peeps is interested in it Oh interest is
no real difference in the sixes there
might be a slight difference in size but
really really are the female slightly
bigger slightly slightly bigger than the
male
nice to see though so that's not the
biggest of raptures in the world that
will feed on birds largest guinea fowl
and their hunting strategy is exactly
what it's doing it likes to perch so
much of a pursue hunter there's the
facial shot
it doesn't really pursue too many too
many birds it's not the biggest it's not
the smallest of raptors but it's not the
biggest either so it really it waits see
something as big as a guinea fowl will
take lizards and snakes and it more
likely just flops down on top of them
are you're interesting that little
contact all
so the the clue clue clue that's
happening a little clicking tensley
might be a youngster Mina move very good
question and there is something we see
all the time
when you're at the bird with a big
relatively large wingspan you'd think
the large Raptors and specially Bulger's
are very very important too for that
they're very big they're not they're the
most agile of birds of ultra so they're
quite clumsy so they want to go up
insert the tree that's not gonna snag
their wings so the other land on top of
the tree with a nest or when they're
perch it's on a dead tree like this so
they can just jump down and sort of fly
into into the air without any branches
or leaves getting in the way none of us
would really know that because we never
spent any time jumping but good climber
prints a tree like that if you want to
jump into a pool or a dam and you want
to jump out of a tree which tree do we
choose the tree with no leaves or the
tree with a thousand branches and leaves
in the way it's definitely about space
and about accessing their obviously
their wings in and out of the tree not
just the landing but also their leaving
but then also first sitting there for
poaching for maybe for drying themselves
from the Sun they need to be exposed to
the Sun or if you're a purged specialist
waiting to hunt you need to be able to
have a maximum field of view otherwise
that you've kind of not picked the right
spot so the way it's facing it's got a
full sort of view in front of it and
everything moving around enjoying the
sunshine and probably looking for some
food ok well we're going to move on see
if we can find tracts of our cheetah
shortly but maybe a few more questions
on these if you'd like send them through
no more questions what a lovely bird
we're going to move on then to to the
northern side and see if we can find any
wonderful cheetah tracks because as you
know the long-standing views
if you're a new viewer well Cheeta are
renowned for moving in the daytime it's
a known as a diurnal daytime sort of
animal it's kind of in response to the
competition there it flies oh we missed
the money shot Craig oh that hunts in
the daytime to avoid the competition
against lion and hyena during the night
Monica when it comes to playing bird
calls
I'm it you need to be very careful in
the breeding season you can affect the
breeding a territorial family will be
surprised by the call that might be
louder than and also you should ever
play it louder than air call if you do
play it you've got to play it once let
it birds respond and then you stop
playing it all together but if you play
it again and again and again you're
going to disrupt the breeding and you
might even displace completely displace
a breeding pair or territorial pair
because the caller here is louder or
it's more incessant than them and you
can completely affect their life so it's
very important to be ethical when it
comes to playing calls play it once see
if there's a response leave it if you're
walking looking for a special or sort of
cryptic colored or hidden bird never
more than once every hundred meters or
so but they're you changing areas and
then a bird will jump out they respond
very quickly to calls but it must also
make sure you're not too loud match the
sort of pitch that that birds gonna play
that otherwise it's like you know trying
to sing against someone who's Pavarotti
you know you know stuck gonna track on
Peter other it's gonna leave now are we
gonna go check a watering hole and seems
like someone else has found someone
drinking
yes and a look at that draft there how
lucky to see a giraffe drinking we have
not seen this for quite some time and we
saw one behind it and we just discussed
from [ __ ] maybe they may go for a drink
and just get in closer
just look at that they're always
friendly legs out to be able to reach
water because of their long necks but at
the same time the worry of being preyed
on by predators is always very big this
is very special for me to see a giraffe
in having its shadow in the back its
reflection in the water and actually
rough sprayed outlets there very well
done job fog and as much of concern of
so much you know blood remaining in the
head they need to bring their heads up
the biggest concern is getting preyed on
when they're drinking by either Lions
cuz they have known from experienced
predators like lions will hang around
the watering holes and come and hunt
them when the drinking a big boy
Sbrocco I have seen that mark there it
has actually to max if you look
carefully and being a male you asking
what's wrong with his neck being a male
males usually fight a lot males usually
fight a lot and I think this one has had
a few fights and if you try to calculate
or estimate the head but vanassa co all
drops horn that so most likely it keeps
hitting when it as soon as it's head or
on the other no is suing its head
because they use the horns to fight all
the Oscars to fight chances are that is
where it gets because we call sneaking
and the Oscars will always hit at that
particular point if you just estimate
the rough height for mother Lucy got two
marks there one on top and the other on
there my guess is those comes from the
fights they usually go through it's very
typical for males to fight females
really fight scratch great comments and
great observation there
sorry would you ask toward Rudolph's
trouble the water
they just slap it and then straight to
the mouth they are not able to suck just
like how that cuts you know will drink
they just slap the water
I think certainly is a car that move in
the background there must have spokes it
a little bit and of course I'm not sure
the giraffe saw it or knew what it was
it will not want to take any chances but
that's why it's leaving the waterhole
and that is really something you see his
challenge of going up there because of
its height alright from one drinking
animal to another drinking animal well
everyone is up that the gremlins stay
away sorry about that
the previous picture that we had of this
lovely bull elephant who is in hi must
and when we first spotted him I am not
sure which part of the story you got it
can towards us with a very intense
swagger and when you do note that bull
elephants a must it's best to stay out
of their way because they do very often
cause nonsense and they're very
irritable and so when you spot that and
the very clear indicator is that they're
actually leaking from the penis area
dribbling a lot there if you can see
there's little dribbles there and that's
actually coming from the penis and very
weight in you know in between the back
legs a very very clear indicator that a
bull is in must another way they do you
also at the star leak from the temporal
gland but we don't often say to people
that that's what you should use as an
indicator because they will also leak
from the temporal gland when they're not
in must it's purely a stress indicator
it's a bit of an emotional or triggered
by emotion so obviously when I do have
all this testosterone coursing through
their blood it will also result in the
Asians being quite highly strung now he
also does as I was saying react with a
swagger towards anything that presents
itself towards him and a vehicle and a
speak vehicle like this he might think
of it as another big elephant and he
just wants to come over and prove
himself as a as a man has a big boy as
you know and this testosterone-fueled
period is very important for elephants
because it drives male bulls like this
to go ahead and join what's the herd and
obviously seeking out females and if it
wasn't for that well we'd probably run
out of elephants because the males do
like to wander off on their own and only
rarely rejoin the herd when this
testosterone starts pumping through
their blood it can however be very
stressful for the herd actually you say
he's got very nice big tusks I agree
with you they're very very thick tusks
it seems like the might be a but brittle
one and I wasn't done to think I
actually saw if they were nice and
smooth but he is a very good-looking
individual he's a rather large elephant
I have seen bigger but I haven't seen
too many much bigger than him around
here so very very nice good looking
elephant but as I was saying that can be
quite stressful for the breeding herd
because he wants to force himself on
them you know a Monique it can be a
little bit uncomfortable for for the
male's it's um you know it's I wouldn't
think that you've ever experienced any
any kind of not that I have either it's
taking steroids or just getting into a
really frustrated time that everything
irritates you and while it also comes
down to a sexual thing for for these
elephants to they really are looking for
the girls and with the frustration of
not having them it does sort of heighten
it
you know sort of emotional state that
they're in so they're just aggressive or
irritated with everything that comes
near them and as I say the first thing
he did was really come towards us in a
very intent motion of out of our way
boys
otherwise I'm gonna flatten you so
that's you know very easily identified
by experience of being around big bull
elephants like this I've had him like
this on foot and over 20 years I've had
you know I can't count how many times
I've been around elephants like this so
I understand that it's just keep your
space and he will then continue as he is
now normally losing interest with you
after you know a few minutes if you
remember that at this time you keep
yourself a nice escape route so if he
did have to spin around now and come
towards us then we'd head off then
speaking of head off it seems the
gremlins are attacking again they say
I'm not sure what he has I think we're
having a reptile now after having some
two male giraffes or almost coming to a
fight and they were almost necking and
they hit each other very hardly and so
squid a big bang we had and I'm guessing
we might be having a monitor lizard
doing a little shimmy I've never seen a
crocodile in this water hole and it
might be kind of looks like mantra
lizard to me very good look hundred
percent yes Sumatra lizard I'm always in
them the bank over the side of the water
but this one is having some beautiful
fun think you look he's having a great
fun in the water look at is just feeling
good and enjoying the swim there and one
it is still left right
hopefully nothing is bringing it down
because Crocs here would imagine maybe
there could be a crocodile trying to
bring it down and eat it but it's just
enjoying and having a great time here in
the water and this one big difference
between these lizards and the rock
monitors because this one's will be
found in and out of water in many times
they've always mistaken them for
cocktails or baby crocodiles from a
distance and it surely it is a monitor
lizard you can see the head out Ruby
you say this is so cool I'm also
enjoying it here with fog and we are
seen for me something I've not seen
before a monitor lizard in water and
just having its best and you'll notice
once in a while it's a British turn out
because they need the tanks out to smell
the air every girl you're asking how big
can they grow some of these can go up to
1.5 meters Abigail 1.5 meters is how big
they can grow and they weigh a lot more
than the rock monitors so this one could
go up to 1.5 sometimes 1.8 meters in
length and emissions in seem to come out
of the water after having a nice suit
how cool is this yes Abigail you can see
it now so anything 1.5 to 1.8 is typical
length for a monitor lizard to different
come out just how you come out of the
pool and you want to warm up a little
bit but it does have to be sure what's
happening on the outside world and the
tan is always out every one or two
seconds and if you look the tank
carefully at the very end it slipped
into two and they used the tank to smell
the air and that way from the air they
can tell if there's any prey close by or
any enemy close by and even if
pray they are also able to know what
prey it is and even the distance just by
smelling the air and the tongue being
split into two or legatee tulips as you
see like sometimes in the snakes it
helps it to drop more information
chromic you're asking is the monitor
lizard dangerous for humans no it is not
in general monitor lizards have not been
known to attack humans and for example
if they come out of the can a comic the
monthly that will either go back in the
water or it will move away and I'll tell
you what they are very very fast
you saw it slowly and slagging try to
come out of the water when you see them
full speed
oh they are very fast very very fast
creatures because that's one of the best
defense in a mechanism taking off to
flee speed because they have not been
known to fight back very well always
they blend in very well especially the
front part of the head they blend in
very well
so my firm day of life how are you and
very good for having launched the day of
life people very excited we were
yesterday and that's a second one of the
monies listen and I'm sure this could be
appear and they could be melting that's
my guess but I tell you in this
particular water hole we have not seen
or personally I have never seen a
crocodile here maybe today but it's not
easy just a cockerel just to come out of
the blues this particular wood hole here
we could the twin water hole does not
have any Crocs but again you never know
but I've never seen any Crocs here and
maybe that's one of the reasons this
monitor lizards are going in there with
a lot of confidence because we have
known crocodiles have gone for monitors
and have you know killed them and eating
them you see the movement is are very
different from a croc when they move so
this one's tend to remain a bit clearer
from the ground and see Crocs tend to
move like we do bellies or right on the
surface of the ground and you can tell
the drag marks over monitor lizard and
of a crocodile are very different
the third one also
minimal that's a perfect question as far
as showing as a third modulus that I've
never seen this many more i have already
seen monetize its meeting outside water
and the theme could be possible but in
general because of the way they admit
they would reach minimu they would met
outer the water could be more out gas
well more comfortable for them than
inside the water now some something
interesting could be happening here
because we have seen a third one which
is quite unusual and they all look to be
in the same size and this I could be
wrong might tell me we could be having
some breathing time here
and either two Mills after one female
bucks I don't remember seeing even two
months later together now not two we got
three so it keeps the turnout because
that way is able to know where the other
one is just look is just following it up
and as I said before the tongue is very
important to demolish lizards that's how
they're able by smelling or getting a
scent of the air they can estimate the
distance of the other monitor lizard and
they can know if they can't see it
they'll have a rough idea exactly where
it is
I'd be more than happy if they could
come out and you see the meeting you
know definitely I got a feeling there's
a bit of love in the air here seeing
three of them together
there could be some maybe meeting going
on maybe not now could be later or it
could have happened but to see
three-month lizards together it's very
unusual and a few of them to me look the
same size
ah good I mean there's a bit of theory
for me either they are fighting or
mating and if they're fighting Hawaii
could they be fighting so I'm trying to
imagine if they're fighting they could
be fighting over mating but at the
moment I haven't seen actual mating
going on and that's why I'm sticking
here for quite some time
and find out what exactly will transpire
any you're asking if the Malta lizards
are more comfortable in water or out of
water I will say it will depend on the
situation they find themselves in if
they the predator that will go for them
you know it's not some it's not in a
veil to easily get it get them in the
water they may choose to stay in the
water but if they know out of the water
they'll flee and take off they'll be
more comfortable out of the water any it
will always depend on the situation or
where they find themselves to be but if
they're near water chances are they
would easily go underwater and hide some
of the Monte lizards like this ones here
the water mantle is that we have known
them that they can go underwater for as
long as one hour you'd imagine how they
do that I do not know but unlike hippos
which will go underwater 3 4 5 minutes
the monitor lizards will go underwater
for a very long time so any my guess is
illustration like where we are now if
there's a concern of maybe an animal or
like a crocodile that will not not go
and get them under water they will
definitely be more comfortable
underwater something is definitely going
on here if you look at their behavior
child of the universe monitor lizards
territorial I would say yes there's one
particular one we have always seen here
the only thing out Simon to a child of
the universe we have not done is maybe
to know it or to market or like how we
have known our little pods here with the
sport patterns I think it's high time we
started you know identifying this
monitor lizards because every two three
days either me or one of the other guys
will come here and see a particular
monitor wizard on this waterhole and I
think it's time we find out my guess is
yes
but I'm not 100% sure but my guess is
child of the universe I think they could
be territorial this one's completely now
out of the water and again you can see
it has a clear difference from the water
sorry I missed a question from Sean
well sorry sorry are shown are your
Christmas can their tanks work
underwater yes the tanks designed in a
way that even well underwater they can
throw them out but I guess maybe more
outside the water than in water because
if you look at that one particularly
shown there the tongue is out more out
in the water than in the water what
would happen is they need to get the air
because it's the air of the droplets out
in the air they need to smell and get
the scent to identify their prey to
identify where the other one is to know
what's happening in the outside world
and then very quickly they bring them
back into what we call the Jacobsens
organ and they read the data of the
information they picked out guests the
tanks are more equipped to work out the
water than inside the water because I
don't think they are going to read very
well inside the water this is pretty
exciting
I've seen they won't find out what could
be happening here and Steve got some
feathered friends yes we found a guinea
fowl helmeted guineafowl and we were
talking only about the the goshawk the
dark chanting goshawk
and this would be a food source that
they would definitely be after which is
very interesting at the guinea fowl
where's about 1.3 kilograms or so is
what that's about 3 pounds and the dark
chanting goshawk weighs maximum 6 600
700 grams so it's almost twice the size
or twice the weight marvelous said to be
able to pursue or catch a bird like this
very likely feeds on quite a lot of it
before maybe flying up into the tree and
I do apologize I was doing some reading
before that the dark trance in goshawk
does actually pursue some fast prey but
it's not its primary form of hunting
spends a lot of its time waiting on a
perch
just like the Gabbar goshawk in the
chakra this little sparrow hawk which
are more pursue specialists they do
pursue fast-moving birds through there
through the undergrowth or through the
thickets Sparrow and SheiKra being a
specialist in that marvelous man should
be able to kill something twice your son
or twice your weight and then what do
you do and can't eat all of it their fee
for some hungry chicks I would say but
you can tell it's quite a warm afternoon
give me fallow enjoying some respite in
the shade there I wonder with those
cheetah cubs if we found them were they
chase off to some guinea fowl that would
be quite funny quite something to see
but we didn't find any tracks of them
coming in so very likely they're still
in the North there maybe they've moved
off further north who knows it's one of
those things you don't find the tracks
you can just assume well you can't
assume anything really if you haven't
find any activity I want to disturb
these guinea fowl
they are enjoying I'm willing to stop
Craig I don't want to chase them out of
their little shady spot you ever look at
them again can actually see the
difference between the three of them the
one on the left and the one on the far
right have got a different sized cast on
the head and the one in the middle is a
lot smaller can you see that I'm
wondering if it is a juvenile the one in
the middle that's just coming in to sort
of plumage it's just growing any fell
we're breeding just a few months ago and
they grow very very quickly very
important buffer food for lots and lots
of predatory animals around here and we
don't know actually how many guinea fowl
actually get fed upon by leopards and
cheetah and caracal and serval as James
has said before about scrub here we
don't know how many of them get fed upon
because it's just such a quick and easy
meal and you don't really find the
remains like you do of a big kill
some uh9 very good question I just need
to correct myself first not that one in
the middle has moved its head and Anna
looks the same as the other citruses a
bit of a trick of the light
some uh9 you want to know if there's any
other any of the birds named after the
name and the boo-boo is named after
they're named they make a lot of boo-boo
sons and we get the southern down here
up north you get the tropical boo-boo
and there's also the bird called the
book my kitty cuz they make a noise
called pop pop my kitty kitty
so that's an interesting one I think
there's a couple others that I'm trying
to think of most of the Afrikaans names
sort of like the old South African
language of Afrikaans which is a mixture
of Dutch and German a little bit of
French a little bit of Malaysian in
there as well there a lot of their names
for birds is named after what they sound
like like a go away bird is called a
quick way fool well a quick way bird
because if that's the noise it makes a
lot of the bird names and animal names
that they've named are actually
specifically because of what they sound
like
very descriptive language Afrikaans in
everywhere in form and just sneak around
these guys you guys move into the bushes
there well seems like David's monitor
lizards have already made it and
possibly produced babies
well I don't know what Steve is talking
about this penalty might have babies
because now we're seeing much better
it's like one fully grown one and two
young ones you can see one moving there
that's pretty young baby very very young
and a thinker it was hiding and a hole
maybe when all the commotion was going
on it just came out from the hole and
want to join the rest cuz I will see
like three fully grown ones and the tiny
baby just trying to move slowly we have
those two there and very good fun and it
got a third one there and they must have
made a baby very quickly Mina more very
good question
do animals get sunburned I think so if
any animals apart from that he puts a
too much out on the Sun they would get
sunburned and that's why it always he
for example reptiles like what you're
watching know the monitor lizards if it
gets definitely too hard for them that
go in the water I'm not very sure of
reptiles for example but I would say
hippos would get some mud definitely if
they are out in the water for a long
time but I think the other animals Jose
in Africa have adopted and maybe are not
able to get you know son unless of
course the very young ones like small
young elephant calves or a young you
know want a lizard like this one moving
I highly doubt they get sunburned
they're very well designed with your
skills and your skills to protect them
from the Sun but you won't go back in
the water would you be more comfortable
in the water are you looking for
something to eat let's find out where
she wants to go
my guess is going to water and cool
yourself or you won't learnt how to use
your tongue you can see
and you ask him whether they opes Oh
abandoned their babies while they're
still eggs normally the females will
come back to the eggs to hatch them
because that's time they are hatching
them of the times they hatch it's always
very crucial they'll get other animals
that you may come and prey on them for
example jackals so the females will
always come back on G to lecture when
the hatching is complete they get to
move with their babies and I'm talking
of either crocodiles or even monitor
lizards they need to take into safe
areas for example like in water or in
big holes where they'll hide them to see
them mature and grow so females will
always attempt one about too much and
ritualize the help in breaking the eggs
and taking them to safety they need to
help them like you know to show them
around and from there they'll be able to
survive she seems to be on the move I'm
not sure where she wants to go but my
guess was should have gone I didn't
whole which is just learning her ups and
using her tongue to smell food when she
becomes mature she'll be quite good and
mancha the mother be like well done and
she's chasing some insects Maceo asking
what they eat they'll eat eggs of
smaller bars
they'll eat insect any rodents they get
and you know any shrimps around the
water area they'll feed with all that
and it could be going in there - look at
this anything they can grab I'm not sure
- got anything massive air
in velocity prey those who preyed upon
by big egos
Jemma how are you and yeah with a big
month elicit it's a smaller one I highly
doubt that should happen maybe unless
it's a scenario of say a water monitor
lizard eating oats a rock multi lizard
by virtue of where the water model is at
being bigger in size than the rock
wizard but that would be when maybe the
situation of hunger or drought or they
don't have much to it but that's really
happens I haven't seen that or I've not
you know had it documented by anybody I
would highly doubt that would happen but
there could be a scenario I mean this
one's when fully grown as I said they're
much bigger and almost twice in the
weight of the rock monitor lizards
she's definitely busy looking for
something by the way you see the turnout
actually sorry I may not be able to know
how they how big their eggs are I may be
able to find out that for you
Wow but my guess would be slightly
bigger or maybe two times as big as
trying to imagine the monitor lizard
hatchling coming out maybe the size of
two chicken eggs but the sheer guess but
I'm sorry actually I have no idea how
big they are but I'm sure at one point
I'll be finding out and let you know on
the next driver beautiful putts in this
one has er
but still continue enjoying this monitor
lizard SIA finding out what they want to
do and let's find out where ruff is
heading to right now
well everyone on Torchwood Travis is a
couple of roads one is called Lian check
and this road that I'm on now is called
Lian tree road so I'm just trying all
the Lion roads in the hope that we find
the Torchwood pride of lions because I
thought that might be our best bet and
last time the first time I was on
Torchwood we have we went on lion track
and found the Torchwood pride so I've
just done that now we didn't find them
but now online tree Road sort of in the
southern section of the Torchwood
Traverse and just trying to see it's
been very quiet after we saw that
elephant at LED wood dam or LED wood
water hall which is right next to
Torchwood Lodge we haven't seen too much
else in the way of big mammals seen some
birds lots of trees of course because we
could never say that we haven't seen
anything it was one of the most
frustrating things that are always used
to hear from my students when when I was
an instructor for one of these wildlife
training colleges and I used to often
say to them when they got back from
their game Drive well what did you guys
see in the gars guy mmm we are nothing
I'm like hey how did you not see
anything because the basis of guarding
comes down to trees and birds because on
every single Drive you will see trees
you will see birds I can never say that
I have not seen anything because I
didn't drive with my eyes closed
otherwise we would have been gotten by
that elephant to start with if we even
made at this so lots of things to be
seen we just am obviously trying to find
something special that we can sit and
watch and that it's nice and interesting
I like to sort of concentrate on birds
and trees when we're walking now debajo
the beauty about the Graduate Kruger
National Park here in South Africa is
that it's a it's it's an area the size
of Israel it's about 2.2 million
hectares and the animals do move across
this entire
space and sometimes it's sort of like
many migrations it can almost seem like
there's no animals here and then you
come around a bend in a road and this
it's just full of animals
and that can be sort of just from little
area to little area and also from time
to time you know on Juma sometimes it's
full of elephants and at other times you
you really struggle to find even one and
then other times there's you know up to
ten lipids in the area and city lions
and then other towns seems like they're
all gone but they move and groove as
they feel fit because there are wild and
free and that's the beauty of it we come
out you never knowing what to expect and
while all we can do is put our selves in
the right places at the right time and
normally it's just the luck of the draw
but the longer you're out there looking
for things and trying also to work out
where the animals have been moving and
try to work out a little bit of pattern
then you can try and catch up with them
but like this morning with the cheetah
at least we know that they're right on
the boundary of Juma and I'm very much
hoping that they possibly cross back
into Juma this afternoon and Steve's in
that area just checking hopefully he
gets lucky over that side well we're
also hoping that we get lucky with the
wildlife
Anke thanks for saying you like my
philosophy oh yeah we go to boho yes
some antelope and we should never
discriminate between antelope because we
get overly excited about some rare
species but if it wasn't for Impala
there wouldn't be a lot of the Predators
around that we find on a regular basis
because they form a major part of the
food source of these predators around
here especially Leopard so we need to be
thankful for the presence of Impala and
I would say some of some of the time
they do also feed on warthogs but a lot
of the time Impala now Scott there are
some animals that do move in and out of
the Kruger National Park
and those animals mostly the warthogs
jackals lipids caracal and and any
number of other smaller little creatures
Genet and civet you know they can very
easily get under the fences and it's
very often down to Jekyll's and warthogs
that make the holes or the it's like
burrow like holes underneath the
electric fences and then that makes it
easier for other animals to sort of
cross that boundary as well but I've
even seen leopards jumping over a three
meter electrified friends so it's not
impossible for them to go over as well
just in general they'll take the easier
route which would normally be underneath
through water Barrow as well dee is yes
they are boarders the greater Kruger
National Park of South Africa does
border on Zimbabwe and Mozambique
so at crooks corner right at the corner
of South Africa we can look at three
countries we can be standing in South
Africa and we can throw a stone across
to either Zimbabwe or Mozambique and
that's crooks corner that's the meeting
of the machi Limpopo and the la Veuve a
river right at that corner is the the
boundary of the of South Africa Zimbabwe
and Mozambique but that's part of the
greater Kruger National Park because
remember it's a transfer and tier Park
it does go across into Zimbabwe and
Mozambique as well so the rivers
literally form the boundary between the
countries and on the outer edges of the
National Park it is then fenced so you
know there are places sometimes where it
the fence is down and that needs to be
monitored and then the guards would
repair it and and fix it up now adèle
the this part you know the the agreement
with the sand parks or the south african
national parks would be with these some
private property owners like in the sabi
sands
they would need to be fencing the
perimeter sufficiently that it would be
keeping elephants and lions in specific
inside and also to keep people out so
that's the major goal of an you know the
boundary of national parks I would say
in the major part it's actually to keep
people out so that is how the the
private landowners were then obviously
in order for them to benefit from the
greater Kruger National Park and all the
animals that would then move in and out
of their property they would need to
sufficiently have fenced off their
perimeter and they would obviously be
stringent controls and theirs
each and every single person that comes
in on into the sabi sands pays an
entrance fee and that all goes to the
greater conservation maintenance of
these of these particular areas but for
the roads the fences the staff not in
terms of the lodges not star for the
lodges but staff for maintaining the
fences for anti poaching and a very
important part being that of road
maintenance because if left alone roads
will be probably your primary source of
erosion and degradation of your land so
they need to keep that all up to scratch
and you know they would have a
management team a conservation
management team that would be having the
targets and goals for the year and all
the different things that they would
need to be completing as a part of the
daily weekly monthly yearly schedules
and making sure that it's all up to
scratch in line with the sandbox Scott
the poaching problem in the Kruger has
obviously escalated in the in the last
ten years the majority being around
rhino and the obvious very lucrative
side that rhino horn brings on the black
market so that is attracted a lot of
poaching into the Kruger National Park
and the sabi sands is now different
obviously with the sabi sands being
more of a sort of private entity within
this public government entity they do
have a little bit more hours I would say
in the way of input monetary wires in a
smaller area so their teams they're
poaching teams would maybe be a little
bit more efficient but it's it's mostly
down to them having a smaller area to
work with
remember those national the the parks
anti poaching teams they've got massive
massive tracts of land to deal with and
so it's it's it's it's an unenviable
task for those guys having to protect
that that huge tract of land and then
you've also got the problem of it being
a trans frontier parks you've you've got
guys coming across the border South
Africans going across to that side it's
it's it's it's almost impossible to
control but the guys do do their best
but it overall I would say that there
probably are fighting a losing battle
because the numbers have dropped in
terms of poaching incidents but I don't
know I'm not I'm not much of a sinister
I do probably think that the major
reason why the poaching incidences have
decreased is because these rates there's
less rana around to poach anyway that's
that's a story for another day
let's carry on trifon these lions while
I do off to Steve
well we are on our northern boundary
right now just having one last look to
see your first G to come back in
Erickson from Juma followed them this
morning they sort of went north east ish
from where there were so because they
move in the day there's always that
opportunity that they could have come
back across so I'm just checking the the
road this is quite a quite a busy road
as well because there's an access to a
few of the lodges and landowners on the
side so tricky to see the tracks but
it's important to check roads like this
to see if anything comes in and outers
what we do quite often especially in the
mornings but if you're looking for
cheetah a very big move during the day
so good time to do that boundary patrol
as it's commonly known and so we're
gonna keep going here and if they have
been coming by the next kilometer so
we're going to go back in towards where
Tandy and Columbo we're lost teen last
night I believe someone tried to follow
up this morning but didn't find any
tracks maybe they were 100% sure where
she was Craig and I are gonna go there
see if we can find Mia any leftovers of
that maybe they're still there but we'll
figure out where the closest water is
from that section and then follow on
from there and see how lucky we can be
to see the little Columbo with some
light I know lots of you are screaming
again yes please love to see the lumber
well as its notorious for this northern
section there's big drainage we better
go through the signal gets a bit but
sneaky so let's quickly go to David
while I get through this dark pitch
oh yeah we don't want us stiva losing
signal some areas always you know up and
down and it'll happen this you know
disappears but we are doing well we are
only out say we have faced what
southwest boundary and the birth some
news of the new comers they've been
spotted somewhere I just got the news
over my general radio and I'm trying to
find out if I can reach there and
hopefully they'll be out having seen the
sticks this morning I don't mind seeing
my second page of lions in one day which
would be pretty exciting
temperatures getting better but could be
an impossible mission there go ahead
minimal
minam oh why thank you for keeping us
busy can two prides of lions bingo with
each other I don't think so
as much as we say the male's a
territorial also the females are equally
territorial and mainly for one reason
food food so it's not possible to see
the middle going for each other and you
have even seen we have always thought is
only males that fight you know for
territory or for females or for food
over some other resources like that but
females I can tell you also go for each
other so should the territories will
move overlap we have seen the lead
females for example in the new comers
get to do the number I or the one that
got a wound we have seen the mature or
the leaders in the pride of lions you
know going for each other so yes that
would not happen and you know I ideally
in nd ideal conditions we don't have to
preserve lions you know sharing even
food live alone food even a territory
they always make sure you keep to our
territory and we'll keep to ours but
what will happen is we have seen them
crisscrossing territories you know
they'll overlap we'll see the sticks say
in Juma area just going through they
disappear for a couple of days and then
you see the new comers still come
through but to see them so close to each
other is quite an issue and the same
case would apply to the males you know
there are workers the Birmingham boys
that always have separate spaces so
they'll always want respect their spaces
and that uses a lot of conflict
so we'll just follow that lead and
hopefully see you that we are going to
see the newcomers that I have not as I
saw them last night that was very
interesting just laying down as usual
buy some water pan after having feasted
the whole day and they were very in very
good spirits and today the sticks had
eaten some water back I think yesterday
so we'll find out one and Kuma's want to
do today or if they want to go for
another kill who knows
but as per last night when I left them
the bellies were looking very good I've
been asking my question myself a
question where are the males I mean
could be going to two weeks or three
maybe we haven't even heard them you
know either roaring or any trucks being
seen somewhere no news and it has been
very quite I'm not sure the Birmingham
is having been here longer than the
Evoque has I'm like they're like okay we
don't want to be involved in a fight
because the Lions are equal intelligence
when they realize well we might be hard
to the fights they might be quite but
either way where are their focus no
males for the last couple of weeks
Angola you asking at what edge world the
male lions believe the pride anything
three to four years they're quite good
mature and at three four years they'll
be good to go and live their life and
maybe go establish their own coalition
go join a new coalition oh you know
something like that but three four years
is a good age for them to leave and of
course I'm sure you know the females
will always stick around as much as by
about two and a half years yes sexually
sexually mature they'll stick around
with a pride and they'll not go anywhere
but three four years the males have
established a bit of main strength and
they can go and introduce themselves to
a coalition of Mayors but once in a
while
you see a male by itself or two before
they get a coalition so you go again for
the coast from child of the universe if
we go the question right is it how well
they define the boundary of the
territory yes and tell the universe how
are you and your question is how well
they define the boundaries of the
territory a few teams come in play and
one is always the resources of food and
how big the habitat is and males will
always send makizushi
they also roar and that marks the size
or the acreage of the territory they
want to be in that's what really counts
of course the habitat is small and not
much resources then also the area of the
teacher is equally small and got a small
voter here and this is the hooded
vulture quite a special place it's got
blending in very well there
I'm not showing that stocks of cracker
somewhere or kill somewhere or it's
waiting to oops
see on deal there I mean Elena crusted
rola trying to
intimidates the vault chat live I do not
know why he/she behaved that way she
came like almost to the vaults of the
head you know and almost popped it with
a beak and the voice was like get out
over here I'm bigger than you
this is a beautiful lilac breasted
roller always this turned out in Africa
of all the beautiful birds you got here
this one's always turned out for the
beauty and this is my favorite bad all
the beautiful colors they've got and one
of the best things when you see them
looking down and looking for prey either
bees or beetles on the ground and they
just fly right down pick them up and
back to where they are and feed them or
rather feed on them what are the
smallest body lots of colors in it very
difficult to tell males from females
having a look at the vulture Vince you
said this is a very beautiful I agree
with you and I'm sure you might have
hardly saying it's my favorite but it is
so beautiful and especially when you see
them in flight you know they just
unbelievable they spread out you see
greens in them lilacs in them heights in
them compare it to the vulture there
which is much bigger and it doesn't look
well it's equal before my own you know
status they need maybe to blend in but
the lilacs are always fantastic as I
said especially in flight whittany
should see the hooded vulture is all
here there will be in twos threes fours
well we'll just tell us where your
friends are but in the meantime let's go
to Steve and find out what he's up to
thanks David well we have come back to
or back into Juma away from the the
northern boundary so we're no signs of
the cheetah class at the moment but we
are not far away from where we left Andy
in a little rebellious cub last night oh
just having a look see if there's any
sign for a sign of anything coming out
and we'll go in there quickly see if
there's anything left I doubt there be
anything left of that carcass and in
most likely they've moved off but we'll
have to give us a bit of an idea ideally
in the morning that would be the best
time to try and find them but no one
found any tracks in an erroneous or
maybe the insights and they have still
been in there
will we be lucky
willow wonder of course I will be of
course Monday morning actually Taylor
almost wanted to swap shifts with me and
then I said no I can't I've got to be on
in the morning I have promised a
medicinal Monday morning which is
tomorrow so Baron be prepared I am doing
a wonderful tree tomorrow we're just
gonna go off yeah
she wasn't far off the road here
yesterday actually that's not the one
the next track will be the best one to
access it'll take us directly towards
where we left her with that little Dacre
wasn't that cute her running around with
that Dacre kill stealing it from mum
naughty little girl she is definitely
becoming a very fine young leopard and
we are very very lucky to be able to
spend this time with him those of you
who've been watching the show we've been
documenting her from the day pretty much
the day she was born which is really
something special I only started in
January and got to spend pretty much
almost every day with her firstly we had
to take shifts cuz if because everyone
else wanted to spend time with her too
but there were times when I'd see at
least once a day
very special
there is very special indeed
Malcolm I will do my best to find your
feline wonder always drive very slowly
yesterday she was so camouflaged she
could almost drive over if you're not
careful obviously she would move
beforehand but you don't want to
influence the cat's in any way so we're
looking for some shade you for a spot
this is right where we left her it was
right here on the right-hand side there
is I'm not going to get out and grab the
pieces I can see the draw of the day I
don't if you can see Kreger I don't want
to get out lest she's here somewhere
first gonna do it'll scratch around here
before and just see little bit sorry the
cars in the way there's the leg well it
looks like Ralph Kirsten has been far
luckier than myself key it is the Duke
himself hello mister and he's coming
straight up towards us a lovely little
bit of marking now he might walk
straight past us on the side here hello
mister there we go and he's gonna shift
slowly past the back of us and just as
soon as I've got enough space that I'm
not gonna irritate him I'm going to turn
around I might just go forward a little
bit and in tune but we are in luck
thanks everyone celebrating so am I so
we're just gonna keep ours on in there
it's a little bit tight in this drainage
line just to turn but nothing never fear
and then driver will do it and don't get
stuck now
a little bit of work on the sandy bank
to go and he had the squirrels battle
going crazy as Jim Gardner walks along
he's now hitting on to gary main so this
was he came along perry made into this
to block yet towards Chitra
Chitra damn hospital bit of a
territorial loop I think and up the main
round I'm just gonna respond yeah we're
all standing by I'm West in Ghana he's
now just come out of them low Nene and
he's heading on Geary main in an
easterly direction oops sorry Davi okay
sorry everyone is a little bit of
gremlins yeah we are deep down inside a
drainage line so that's the reason why I
wanted to just get a little bit closer
well we watch King gonna probably go for
a Pew and and then you know continue on
he has had a little bit of mocking
sessions and when we swim that the day
he was nice and full he had a little bit
of blood on his neck we knows that
yesterday morning she sometimes these
days all morph into one didn't seem to
have too much of a pure they he did seem
to try but now the squirrels are all
starting to go ballistic around us but
let's let's catch up with him before he
disappears
wonderful see what I mean always expect
the unexpected we came out with no real
intentions we just thought we'd come and
see whatever we find and I actually said
to Davi a little bit earlier because
this morning I was following checks
following text following text and I
didn't find anything then I was chasing
much fuller all morning and this
afternoon I said I'm any checks me off
I'm just going to be looking and we
found an art bull elephant in must and
now surprise surprise the Duke
all just coming up side you behind him
I'm gonna piss up to class just give him
the spice it's a nice incline here that
he's going up and just check my map to
see happy
now Adelle this is one of the reasons
why I love what I do some days can be
slightly frustrating but you know what I
don't need to sit in traffic I don't
need to have the daily grind you know so
this is that's absolutely amazing and
thank you to all the viewers for
allowing me to bring this to you because
it's because of you that I'm sitting
here right now with the Duke and it's
great that I'm able to show you as well
and so that's why I just keep on doing
what I do and I do it with a smile I
have that beautiful dual app on him and
he looks like he might be sort of half
interested in whatever might be around
whether it's other lipids or antelope or
something that he might potentially
chase down he's looking in a little bit
of a boisterous mood so all we can do is
just keep following and I'll just wait
for him to shift now you know go up
behind him
beautiful kitty cat there he goes
now child of the universe I don't know
often gonna have ignited with any
females recently Sammy who Kamui that
has been writing well that we know of
that has been mighty what should do Lou
but could have without us knowing that's
always a possibility materi is look at
doing a typical rubbing and then and
then after that then he does his little
spry so I love watching them in their
garden ed pond legs and lift up like
that they head into the branches it it
always makes me think they're being
really playful but they're obviously
it's just part of the the marking
routine know know what road this is the
rockin direct cars even to follow us
it's not always such a bad thing if
they're coming in the same way are you
and I say well I don't know but we're
sitting with ting Ghana but I'll tell
them it's that right just east of them
law meanie so let me just lift everybody
else na stations offer from wildest in
Ghana has lift the road again he's
headed into the block he had it just up
the hill from all Nene in an easterly
direction and then he turned right onto
that first ride I don't know what it's
called with the towel on and then he's
headed into the easterly block I'm
following up on him so you guys can
always direct teen
he's going today to Mach 9 it's up that
he goes up on top no there is already
fish that was fast
Robert the longest distance that I have
even followed a leopard for was in
Namibia and it was probably close on a
hundred kilometers Ramat but a little
bit different landscape to what we have
here I would say here in the live felt
or this particular area the longest have
followed a leopard was probably on
sowlaty Game Reserve and looks like he
might be watching something as he
spotted something beautiful on top of
the termite mound there well just um let
him settle and if he stays I'll
obviously try and get us a bit of you I
just want to see if he's maybe spotted
something from there but it's got a nice
vantage point and he does look like he's
looking but yeah and I thought I would
say probably either about 15,000
hectares is the longest of followed
leopard but that was with students and
we had the possibility of just
continuing following for the you know we
actually followed him for two and a half
days so you know we pretty much must
cost the entire game reserve so that was
very very interesting as well if you
follow a lipid on it's very nomadic
pathway as it just shifted around the
reserve on its side
now Kiwi who's a new viewer thanks once
again for your question that's great to
have you guys involved with us and a
part of this as it's happening you know
live right now the leopards and lions
don't particularly think of humans as
food
we haven't traditionally or historically
been food for predators like that it's
only sick and and sort of injured or old
animals that might potentially start
thinking of us as prey in general you
know they see asana as another apex
predator and so they possibly think of
us as competition but not generally as
food I mean I'm pretty sure that if I
set here with an open wound dripping
with blood it could potentially attract
them another hyenas would be the first
to probably respond to that and and the
lions and leopards could eventually as
well because they could see an
opportunity but they're not generally
looking at humans as food you know
historically and evolution wise they do
focus on the on the true animals that
they've hunted over thousands of years
and humans never really fallen in that
category so I think they've just
instinctively realized that humans are
dangerous and they're more wary of us
then think of us as food now yes settled
a little bit so I think I might just got
a little bit around like that so we can
maybe get a beautiful view on his face
what do you think of that
nice and slowly and he's right up on top
of it too much perfect for us I'm sorry
there are some branches and things that
just rub up against the side of the
vehicle we are in the thick of it so
that's why you might just hear a bit of
scratching going on but these vehicles
are made exactly for that just a little
bit don't block his view but that we can
see his face that's it and it's about a
half an hour or so away from that you
know that called an hour here he is
sitting on top of a termite mound and
just scanning the area sometimes lipid
cans stay up in trees and spot for
animals but they do need to move around
the territory not only for sort of
keeping other would-be competitors out
but also to literally hunt down the prey
so they'll move into an area where they
can then lie in ambush or they can stalk
up on the prey and I mean there's a
chances are eventually if they're to lie
up in a tree that something eventually
would come underneath him and they could
jump down and catch it or see some prey
from up there and I can actually see
something apart I'm moving in front I
think that might be what he was watching
they just moving through the thickets up
there and I'm pretty sure if he just
disappearing and the thickets there but
that's definitely what he's been
watching that's what he had his eye on
as soon as he went up it was just quite
fleeting so sorry about that but there
was a ram Impala that I saw just cross
over there and now Dingaan has put his
head down for a little snooze it looks
like but I think we'll stay right here
and not go anywhere because it's perfect
timing that we found him maybe we'll see
him go down
for a drink a little bit closer to
sunset and we can spend some time with
the Duke what better way to spend your
afternoon hey I will leave the other
guards to go and find some other things
and keep the show variable but for our
part I think what do you guys think I
think I'm gonna be hanging with 10 Ghana
for the rest of the drive but you can
tell me if you want me to go somewhere
else but you'll have to vote for it I
think because I think mostly people will
say that I should be hanging with this
guy if I'm the deciding vote so I'm
saying we stay but you guys can decide
for yourselves Christophe you're saying
that ting Ghana seems to be more noble
and then who Komori well that suppose
definitely comes down to him being quite
a bit older and you know you're saying
also elegant well absolutely
but you know sometimes that does come
with age who Kamui a lot younger than
him and so he's got that youthful
exuberance about him and you know
youthful energy as well and I think
hookah movie hasn't quite fold out as
well just yet does still have that look
of a youngster especially in his
shoulders and in his body his head is
very big which shows that he is going to
be a very very good looking cat but I
think he's got a little bit of filling
out to do and well I think they both
very very amazing cats in the iron rods
the Duke obviously having been around a
lot longer but who Komori as an upcoming
his is just as just a special but unique
in his own way okay so it seems like
it's a done deal
you guys think I'm staying with him well
you were gonna have to convince me
otherwise because I was just asking but
as I say if ITIF the deciding vote I
would
I would veto the rest but they always
want to know what everyone thinks and
sometimes it can get you know not boring
but a little bit frustrating maybe just
sitting with the cat that's sleeping but
well we can talk about all sorts of
things we can debate on different
matters like we have started to do about
hukum or eating Ghana and dulu and you
know and we might not see it in Ghana
for the next week so it's always good
just to hang around and we might have
another vehicle or two coming in now so
just so that you understand that it
might be a bit of noise from the
vehicles yeah you can make your area
yeah there
any I think he might be a little bit
hungry because of the way that he was
looking at those Impala
but yesterday morning he had a very fat
belly and he also had a little bit of
blood on his neck so I think he is not
starving that's for sure but well you
never know with lipids they could take a
chance whenever they like but as I say I
think he has fed recently so I wouldn't
put it past him if he actually just
wants to sleep relax maybe drink some
water and you'll always have a look at
Prai if they're around but doesn't
necessarily mean that he's gonna hunt
some of the other guys coming in now say
I think just white a little bit and see
if he shifts his position otherwise I'll
try and get a view from the other side
so it's tricky because you know to get
the lot right and to get the sort of him
facing towards you you know that's one
of the skills that you always need to
work with there's a guide because I'm
always trying to get the guests into the
perfect position to get the photographic
setter but sometimes you go around that
side and you'll turn around and roll
over this way and then you know you've
sort of irritated everybody and so on so
sometimes good just to wait a little
while and see what he does maybe we get
the lot right or you go around that side
and you then get a shot on his face but
then you're facing straight into the Sun
so there's a there's a few things that
you need to play with I just like to
first get into a good position and then
sit in white for a while and then we can
always shift as we see fit
okay I think I am definitely now it
looks like he's gonna go for a little
snooze so I might try just get a a
better view of his of his face because
we've been asked to see him in his in
his full glory
well while our reposition after Rafiki
dies
fantastic news of Shingen a yes canoes
but now we were told idea the who must
met have been seen here early in the
afternoon think that's what you're
trying to trace and find out well
they're here or not here but at least
school usually have one cut and you're
trying to find out where the new comers
are so we wanted to scan around this
area and see if you wanna see them but
this is where they were last seen
anywhere around here so let's just look
carefully Robert that's a great question
what's my favorite lion pride and having
seen the sticks today I think I'll
choose the new comers the sticks maybe
just bit of a concern of the solidia
sorry Leah of the mainstream they had
how to think out go for the new comers
so over those two prides
I think Umar's could be my favorite ones
for now I haven't seen in as I said any
other type any other third or fourth
pride but for those two the sticks and
then who's I think who must from it are
my favorite ones as we look for them so
Roberts keep your eyes open
and we look for them together right
Steve got a spotter too tall anymore
very nice big males are off he's got a
very big bump on his forehead
let's see you pops up look at that there
it is
now as male giraffes get older they get
more calcifications and sort of x
increases which all calcifications on
their head which sort of increases the
strength of the head or the weight and
the head you can see those ossicones
ossicones are the horned and sort of the
head are very very thick which tells you
it's a male the reason why they need
their head to get
sort of heavier and thicker with more
waiters that they swing it around when
they fight it's not fighting around bow
is busy enjoying some leaves of the red
bush willow I wonder if he knows if you
make a lovely decoction out of them
they can serve and to help any abdominal
pain giraffe girl yes we got another
giraffe for you
was there one done this morning then I
wasn't watching the show marvellous nice
big male enjoying it looks like the red
bush willow to me David had one drinking
ah yes I was trying to find some cheater
at the time so marvellous we just heard
him again I don't know if you heard that
but he flapped his ears it made this
very flappy sound I've never heard such
a raw flappity as before I've seen them
flap them I've never heard the noise and
there we all thought giraffes were mute
see how far down he's able to reach to
feed Superbike surger offers a tallest
land mammal and five and a half meters
about eighteen feet and they get up to
about 1500 kilograms so double that
equivalently about 3,000 or so powers
he's gonna move out of shot there as
they do but that is a very big example
of a male that the weights and size that
just gave you this is a guy probably on
that sort of wavelength we're going to
lose him there aren't we can hear the
characteristic sort of them oxpeckers on
his back as he has probably come from a
drink himself at before sook dam because
we are almost there and we tried to
follow up on any signs of tündi and we
found the remains of that that they
could kill and there was nothing left
but a jawbone and some fur and that
killed was here and then I i've got off
a bit and had a bit of the scratch
around and I found tündi scats about 60
meters about that walk that way and so
just the general direction of bats cuz I
know she's gonna want to go drink let me
on the map because it's quite a tricky
thing because where we were is right
over there in middle of my finger and so
if if you know anything about this map
you've seen it before it is equidistant
if Craig guys are just a little bit
there we go it's equidistant to chela
pan purpose of ordering all and we're
Taylor damn so I figured because her
scat was 60 meters in that direction
we're gonna can have a scratch around it
before so damn and see if maybe they've
come this way if not well no doubt we'll
have a little hippo and we'll have all
sorts of other things to see and then
fading that we will have a look at the
other two watering holes cuz this time
of day
it is going to start becoming time for
these animals to start moving as ralph
is showing you with the old Juke is in
Ghana patrolling tortured the old devil
is the fatherless to find him I was
hoping sort of inwardly driving along on
our way to Tandy we'll just see him
because the road we took is the kind of
the road he's been he's been on the last
couple last week or so it's kind of
where we've seen him so just hoping
there is maybe he's gonna pop out but
he's moving some nice some nice distance
Oh darts in his territorial wonderings
I'm also looking for some food no doubt
Shawn indeed Sunday is the queen of
Jummah she's got really good territory
here but so there was a bit of a
encounter between her and the young
should do the female I should do this
for so maybe 5b gonna have more
strengthening in the strength to compete
so I'm losing signal again I'm just
going to quickly finish that off so yes
tell me is the queen of Jummah but she
seems to if we go back onto the map over
here just like the old Duke has done the
old Juke seems to be keeping to this
area over here he's now over here in
tortured Tandy is always over here this
is kind of where she's at even though
Rickson had some tracks over here by the
dam the other day where shadaloo is
coming in sort of this sort of area and
shadow used to sort of be in the sort of
area here we haven't seen her in some
months and that is it for for the female
lipids that I've really spent time with
in the last while but your tummy would
be the most prominent feature
she's definitely them she's the favorite
for most people Chris if that little
bundle of joy that she has but we are
losing a little bit of signal in this
depression we're going to go back over
to ruff with the Duke of Juma himself
look at this everybody just repositioned
and this white is beautiful now let's
teen garnet see what I mean just a smart
reposition just a different angle and we
get this beautiful white coming in on
tooting ghana and we're the only ones
here for the time being but that won't
remain as such because obviously it's in
ghana being as famous as he is and there
will be other people that want to come
and have a look so we just enjoy our
time alone with him right now and before
some other vehicles do arrive
and I always like it the most when I'm
alone especially with a beautiful cat
like this my solitary animals and almost
like to respect him in the way that I'm
sitting with him alone we still do
obviously only allow three vehicles onto
any kind of starting and sometimes less
in more sensitive environments such as
like if there's a cheetah with Cubs or
you know leopard with carbs
it's then normally at one or two vehicle
sighting but obviously I kept like this
that is very obituaries it's one of the
reasons why people do come to these
areas so very important that we bring
everybody in obviously still maintaining
the if it's ethics and standards but
like I've chatted before if it pays it
stays and I can tell you that ting
garner has probably paid for a lot of
the conservation that goes on in this
particular area just by merely having
people here taking photos and they come
back year after year because of
beautiful cats like this aunt in Ghana
obviously being one of the stars of this
area
Torchwood chat with chapter Juma and
very important that we make that
available for people to come and see and
there's the vehicles start to come in
now Kiwi and that's just some of the
birds that are bumping up their lipids
solitaire cats like the rest of your
cats around the world so you know and
I'm not I'm not you know pushing the
question back to you in in any other way
except by saying why aren't lions
solitary that's more the question
because normal cat behavior is to be
solitary so the only gregarious all
sociable cats are lions and then
cheetahs to a certain degree but the
rest of the cats around the world
are all solitary animals except when
they've got Cubs or when they are mating
so that's the normal behavior of cats
lions go against the grain and they're
the only ones that are so sociable so
that's very interesting from that side
and obviously using that as a tactic to
be able to bring down big prey and being
your mega carnivores there we go he's
sitting gone and they're just looking
over towards us so we've got that
curious look I love it when he puts his
ears out like that now I am brain you
wondering if Maria
Dingaan has hunted warthogs like who who
Murray does I haven't seen him doing
that but I'm pretty sure that you could
the viewers would probably be in the
long term viewers would be have all
sorts of different encounters of him and
I would guarantee that he's at least
killed a few warthogs in his life and
wouldn't only be limited to Impala he's
probably taking on some young kudu niala
impala warthogs and you know a number of
other things diecast Ian's book and all
sorts but as I said I haven't seen him
eating any water only Impala I have but
I'm still new to the area sir absolutely
beautiful there to mark man that he's
sitting on just makes for a perfect
ideal sitting with a green thorn here in
front as well it's just as if he knows
that we want to photograph and video him
and he's sitting up in a perfect spot
now inquiring mind with tingoora having
mated with his daughter trendy obviously
that's not ideal it's not ideal and you
you would prefer to have you know
someone like Oh Kumari coming in and you
know at least shifting him into an area
that he wouldn't be mating with his
daughter so you are going to eventually
pick up problems with that kind of
mixing of genes or lack thereof that you
would prefer as diverse mix of genes as
possible so that's why it's it's
actually better if a male that is born
to a female gets shifted to totally
different area and by other males that a
territory territory was you know very
active and very competitive in a
specific area so for whatever reason he
hasn't been pushed out and then that
does land up you know where you can get
these kind of problems and and if that
continues you know the fathers might
think with daughters brothers and
sisters etc you're obviously going to
end up with deficiencies in the in the
cats themselves and eventually that that
kind of breeding does does take its toll
maybe on the first line it might not
particularly show through but you could
also have it coming through you know a
couple of generations later for instance
so now it's not an ideal situation and
that that's obviously unfortunate but it
does happen naturally as well it's just
the circumstances that sometimes prevail
and that's about it he's up may of t
ah ah now I think he is you might be
absolutely right damn just watching him
as he goes past one of the trackers and
we'll just see exactly hi guys
he's hitting in the direction with us
Impala way so I might just spin around
and maybe make a follow
keep up with the old boy
as I said there's three of us in here
now we'll all just give each other space
and give each other
right-of-way at different times we work
as part of a team and we also get the
rewards as part of a team you know I'm
at today be the one that finds three
leopards and then I share that with the
other guys and on other days I might
find nothing and then they sharing it
with me so you know it's very important
that we do it we all share these kind of
encounters the one thing that we do need
to be careful of however is just moving
from sight into sighting without
actually actively going and looking for
some sightings of your EIN because you
know you sometimes get those guards that
are just listening to the radio and if
you've got three vehicles on a sighting
okay so now you also want to come and
have a look but instead of just sitting
down the ride and waiting for your turn
go and have a look in the area you might
find another leopard so that's that's
important I think to remember always as
a guide and obviously I've been here
Ranger and a couple of reserves and in
managing of these guys as well and
that's obviously one of my major big
things is that guard standing in line
just waiting to come in on the sighting
they need to go and do a bit of work on
the iron as well but that's just a
little bit of you know insight into the
life of a guard and some gods do with
some gods don't do but there's not
perfect way in being it it's just I
would say some some ways a better than
others
okay so let's say let's get a hit of
thing Ghana here and just to see if we
can watch him nicely but refugee dive
how's the afternoon going my after is
going well and very nice to know the
tinkin is on the move and maybe his move
might be a some fruit later who knows
beyond this waterhole here just looking
whether he could get something
interesting but nice work there by fog
of camera Walker seeing the trees upside
down in the water and some blacksmith
Halloween feeling on the edge of the
water initially when you got him he had
sent some champions and they sneaked
back in the water but our click on the
blacksmith lapwings which are not very
skiddish and how nice to see the actual
moving and jumping the water grabbing
some insects or a kind of a shrimp or
any insect that could be floating there
but you notice they don't get in the
water very much like other water birds
you know they'll just be feeding on the
edge of the water that's very
characteristic for most lapwings unlike
the big sea herons or stocks that we
read or egrets read inside the water
feeding this ones tend to feed on the
edge of the water
blacksmith lapping they're always being
in pairs and the other one whom she's
not very far from this one here
sometimes they go in the water and they
spoke out the Terrapins
keeps moving and feeling and yeah we
shall just now continue with there was
such we do not see the new comers they
must have hidden themselves somewhere or
they thought they don't want to you know
take more photographs and I thought I
had seen some sticks stick bride this
morning maybe you're gonna swing by
there and find out if they are where I
left them
and let's find out if you're gonna get
them body well okay sorry
[ __ ] okay let's just move on and let the
blood Smith slapping and join itself and
now we are heading to the 6th fret where
I saw them in the morning chances are it
could be where they are I do not think
they might have moved because they had
eaten a lot I think they had a huge wart
about last night and there's some water
pan not from not far from where they are
so chances are that be just hanging
around that area it should be exciting
I'll be similar for the second time and
maybe have a closer look for them and
try and understand the collision they
have been going through of the Skyport
ik mange which I don't think the new
comers have heard that one or they have
ever had was very interesting to the
clients which are pulling through such
an infection and as I said earlier from
what I gathered from my colleagues they
looked rather bad a few months ago and
for them to be where they are choices
are and they'll make it which would be
very good news very good news
well show you asking why Lions kicked
out of a group can it join another group
yes or no it it depends on how its
kicked out but you notice the male's
when they formed their coalition and
they soon by the print of lions and they
noticed the boys are getting big and
they're trying to show you know any
sexual maturity characteristics in them
the mayor always showed up the door and
chances are they'll always go out and
form a coalition it's very difficult to
see for example one lioness on its own
and also it's very difficult for the
lionesses to kick out another lioness
unless for pattern of all regions so
that rarely happens but once the males
are kicked out of the pride as they get
big and they told you know go live your
life go get some new friends live with
they'll always go and hang out with
other males and they have you know a new
beginning for their lives
yeah they'll definitely get some people
to hang out with and very difficult to
see them living on the own leopards are
the only cuts once you know they have
matures go go you're on your own
so layers very social cuts and very
social
I am brain anything three to four years
young males are able to be independent
and they can leave the old life but by
the time they are getting to seven eight
years old was a very mature males and
they could easily in the correlation of
be quite in charge you really have some
dominance when you look at males of
course some males we look bigger than
others some males will have bigger
Mane's than others but unlike you know
other animals where you'll have dominant
sorry just what's a box there it's very
new sure for the Lions to have say a
dominant male or one that's not and
that's what about crying there are two
of them there's a two girls and these
are the common water marks and I think
we lost one of them to the sticks pride
of lions yesterday when the numbers are
still doing good the new home has had a
couple of air warthogs
so let's keep moving forward as we head
to the sticks and hopefully maybe they
might bring another watch back down who
knows is a bigger prize I think than
then Oklahoma's I think they're 13 and
the newcomers are eleven waterboxx
always very close to water and as the
name implies they drink lots of water
and they'll always not stay very far
from water pants or from water holes or
rivers or lakes we've got two types of
water box in the common water box
and we also got another type that's
called the faster water back and the
difference is is always [ __ ] keep moving
for units that's good there okay if you
can catch that far gonna show you sorry
you look on the bumps there you have
that characteristic white ring people
always say they look like you might have
certain Oh words toilet it's a big male
in front there moving
so these are the common water bucks and
the other type is the defensive water
back which are fairly high Trump instead
of a dream you see on the back there
could be a male and a couple of females
heading maybe for drink somewhere
fantastic and maybe Steve has another
surprise for us
well look at what we have found ladies
and gentlemen now I'd be lying if I said
I found it but remember we spoke about
checking the three watering holes before
sook we tell and chill a pan while
braixen went to check via teller and he
heard long hauls and he found Tandy tell
amber is here some way as well but at
the moment we can't see her Tandy is
busy with another Dacre kill the
seemingly Dyke is all over the place in
Juma
she's eating them one at a time a very
very effective mother this wonderful
amber has eaten enough of the last egg
killers not that hungry because she
hasn't quite revealed herself but there
she is that's the look
that's the Tandy we all know and love so
we just sort of east of avoid sailor
watching hole in the thicket Sierra and
would be impossible to have found her
without listening to the characteristic
alarm calls he heard some Franklin just
like I did last night
heard the Franklin alarm calling and
they don't lie what a Sunday it is
indeed Tandy that's quite an ass
distance she's traveled but no doubt
they came down to words had a damn to
drink or alternatively to tambuti down
which is just north just east of north
east of the fire break that cut line up
and bull suck she could have either got
me or to will tell it's really hard to
say but I've no doubt that they
definitely drank and then you know as
Tony does snack on another day care as
you do
fantastic can you imagine trying to find
that focus in the long grass but he'd
spent blessings your favorite cat deed
my favorite cat Azure sauna movie see is
down on the sandy tool under low sea
area it's predicted he'd probably move
away to go and wow some other people
with his antics their attendees here to
say and characteristically a young cub
female cub like Columbo would also stay
in the area mom would just carve out a
piece of her territory but as we do know
males are supposed to leave that's what
the books say maybe 10 Ghana Fanny gave
him a slip around the ears and he moved
off hankie cure I would have been really
nice to see her take him down the
daycare but in the vegetation we in our
doubt who would have seen anything if
we'd been with her maybe it would be
possible to see her moving and then to
see her feeding but to physically see
her take it down
I mean Craig and I the other day with
Oklahoma's in a very open area and we
still missed the takedown shot it's very
very hard in this environment very very
hard it's just another vehicle coming in
to join us they're all very excited to
see a leopard
Superbikes no idea where she dude who is
she is probably in the West and seen
Bambi Lee oh she could be on an Impala
kill just in sani patch I wasn't out
this morning but there was their reports
of her tracks but we know where Tandy is
now she's come all the way to just north
of words hit a dam exactly kind of where
I was pointed to earlier but go quickly
back to the map we're just over here we
are we are you over here so it's
actually very likely that she went up to
this dam a pietà booty from my last
place maybe a loop through like that who
knows who knows what they did but this
karna seems to be where she hangs out
laughs and should do do all sort of on
that side
very interesting dynamics indeed where
is the little playful one David there be
lipids when they meet each other male or
female or rather posture and dominate
the other one through submissive
behavior or through being dominant
so what asana does when he sees an adult
is he just behaves like a youngster and
then they invariably leave him alone so
dominant female we'll call st. mark and
that invariably keeps them separated but
when it does come down to a bit of a
turf war and there do encounter each
other there can be growling that can be
snarling they won't look at each other
I've kind of like sits on opposite ends
of an imaginary line a line that they
know very very well and but if for
example shadaloo moving in is trying to
claim a piece of that land
then could lead to quite a ferocious
battle but neither leopard wants to
fight to the death
neither then wants to get into too much
of a confrontation which could lead to
them losing condition and health and
essentially dying so while we stay at
Tandy I believe the Duke is on the move
as soon as he disappears okay everyone
yeah
ting Ghana is on the move so it's
keeping us very busy trying to keep up
with him but we'll just keep trying our
best just to move with him as he goes
along through the thickets yeah just
keep a little bit of a distance it's not
to disturb him too much you know and
mint we are right on his tail so just
keeping up with him and sometimes you
just want to flank him a little bit just
to see that looks locked he may be be
interested in a little bit of a hunt not
sure and he's had a little couple of
interests interesting looks at some
animals but he hasn't committed anything
yet
we just going around
catching up and it's always just a bit
of Canton Mouse really but that's being
the cat and ting Ghana being the mouse
we following him around here in the
thickets but it's always fun I enjoy
this kind of following behind the cat
especially now I don't know if he's out
on the road yes he is say so just slowly
walking along doing a little bit of
marking and now he's moving a little bit
further south into chatter so he's moved
quite a big distance and from yesterday
where he was literally at for utila damn
have you got him there various moving
through now that's moving through slowly
he's gone into this thicket here so we
need to find a way in hang on good ox
Pina
okay so we're just carrying on keeping
up behind him just that and I try and
get him when he's sitting nicely and
then that's obviously the ultimate goal
when we can relax with him but while we
wait for him or see what he's going to
do let's head on back over to Steve we
haven't missed anything folks the lumber
hasn't come out yet
Tandy's still gnawing away at what
Rickson tells me as a day could kill I
haven't actually seen it every now and
again she looks back behind her shoulder
that's probably which lumber is some way
for there no doubt in the next little
while she's probably ecstatic asar
calling from it says it starts getting
darker we know it becomes quite tricky
for these cats so in the hyena start
moving and the little rebellious rascal
lesson go too far away from the watchful
eye of them otherwise she could land
herself in trouble
so if this is the best view are we going
to be able to get to you disrupting but
how well does their camouflage work as
the season gets drier and drier but what
is good news is this lots and lots of
vegetation around into June a lot of
grass this year there's gonna be quite
good for the zebra population which will
then facilitate the pull the beasts and
the Buffalo also they enjoy nice tall
long grass like this you can think of it
as like sort of open to reserve I wonder
if you can hear crunching those bones is
enjoying all the goodness crunching the
bones to get the marrow out the day
could being a pretty small animal the
bones would be pretty soft for an adult
leopard
a little bit of feeding and then head up
to listen feeding and listen
you might hear they characteristic a
sound of machine gun photographic
photography happening off to the side
I'm gonna do have some very fancy
cameras taking pictures of this very
well photographed Lepidus suppose all
Queens come with a paparazzi
mmm very amazing it almost feels like
you part of the scene with us here folks
so we're just hoping that that little
naughty youngsters going to pop out on
the scene anytime soon come and steal
that meat from mum she was at last week
with her Alfa just quite something to
see watching her run away with the meat
last that was quite comical but again
they find themselves in an area with not
too much in the way of sort of cover if
it means climbing up a tree so if it
starts getting dark we will move out of
this area no real safety net just a lot
of small trees around little saw the
plaster lives which don't offer too much
in the way of climbing potential mepid
would be able to get up there but
wouldn't be able to stay for too long
you might have just got the glimpse of a
group of guests there enjoying this
Leopard wild in the African wilderness
Caron that's a very good question as we
arrived in the sighting I have a very
strong feeling that we might have driven
over some of Tandy's poo there's a very
characteristic smell of leopard scat
Alliance cat smells very similar it's a
deathly decaying meaty sort of smell and
that was the first whiff we got on
entering the scene so yes that's what we
can smell other than that we can't smell
too much from that day care the day curd
would be very fresh so there wouldn't be
any sort of decomposition happening with
it as of yet take a few days for that to
start smelling but hey you know I've got
a very very good sense of smell and
that'll quickly be able to pick up the
blood in the air I do cover such a vast
distance that any sort of movement of
air around I'll pick up much slightest
trace of blood in the end on inward that
come and also very good sense of hearing
they could even hear the bones crunching
out say from some distance
I know all the viewers are hoping
Columbus going to merge and come and
play with her mama she does probably
lead to a little bit of grooming no
doubt a little bit of boisterous play
you can see other's ears are always
cocked always listening I am brain yes
Marceline both male/female lipids for
market territory very similar strategy
and the purpose of the territory mocking
is not only to demarcate against other
females but also to advertise to males
you'll see male lipids I'll stick their
faces in and their it noses into the
urine and they were tested and tested
Jacobson organ with that phlegm and
grimace which will then allow for him
them to realize if this female is an
east hrus where exactly she's yet what's
going on with her
and then he'll probably follow her see
if he can get to him if he can catch her
before she finds another male that is
the way it works variably got about
three females in the territory of one
male or heads up again sorry Craig she
finally put her head up there she is
ah she's moved sorry about that so you
can barely get about three females
within the territory of one male
obviously it's quite loose it's not as
sort of sort of the demarcations aren't
as set as a lot of people would make out
you see there's lots of crossing over
that happens but what that does is Lee
it's a bit of confusion because females
can often come into use just at similar
times and there's no way that that one
male will be able to service all three
of the females in his territory which
means that other males will come in then
so there can be a huge amount of
confusion and sort of the population
with this with lions as well regarding
like food are the parents who is the dad
who is the father
but leopard territories really does
interest me and what I'm seeing here in
the sabi sands is dry is really really
really really interesting just going to
speak to someone coming in here so they
get the best position warrant for Steve
now if you just put your nose right in
there that's probably the best place
that's erection was she's just under the
bush over here that's probably your best
view it's got a important with the
Raider to guide people into their Park
in the right spot obviously if they
don't know where the cat is there might
drive directly into the path and that
you know you need to just obviously
watch for that
okay I think they've got it there we go
mmm okay Karan I don't know exactly how
far into Torchwood am I'm gonna have a
little look on my map and see if I can
work out sort of a distance for you but
I'd I'd say it's probably between two
and maybe three kilometers so maybe mile
and a half um he's walking on along the
mobile Nene drainage which will
invariably come back to to the Marathi
more whitey drainage system which will
take him back to UM way to the dam so
seems to be they like those sort of
drainage systems they walk through
that's where we've seen their old Juke
constantly the last little while even
Murray and I followed the other day and
I stalk with Craig about that last night
that following those drainage is so
important for us to pick up on these
animals because this day Kadare is niala
the giraffe not that they're looking for
giraffe at the giraffe are feeding so
Lions will be moving in series the war
talk that's exactly where their gloom
has killed the water yesterday
Chella pan is just next to the drainage
and because it's sort of downslope
those areas are invariably where the
muddy waters will be formed into more
vegetation you might not see water in
the river system but it is deep sort of
subcutaneous and deep water that's what
gives leaves to the trees a very very
good area for for the herbivores so
that's why you see leopards and lions
moving through those areas very very
important habitat without the drainage
system this whole area to be a very very
different to sort of system so we're
probably going to stay a little while
longer into little slumber materialises
and we really really really hope that
she does
I've come back to where I saw the sticks
re this morning and also chance if they
are still there and in that particular
location now and assuming door fully pet
I think I'm getting so close I can see
some of our friends there so I think
they are still here and they have not
gone anywhere
I saw a camera flash some on the air so
most likely they're here just hold on
and see if we'll get you to the sticks
yes you're still here you haven't gone
nowhere so far will be getting me the
best location
yeah I think we're good to go I can see
only one vehicle because what we do here
you'll always have maximum or three
vehicles at a sighting so it's only one
so we'll try to get as close as possible
and as quietly as possible
we'll press a few you know brushes here
which is fine nothing to worry and it
may be another 40 seconds to be there
just keep holding on
hey good [ __ ] this is where these chicks
are and they're still here I can see
them so let me get the best position for
you
I got [ __ ] it going let me know when to
stop and there we are with the sticks
right and you can see there are some
very very sticks on the foreground and
our friends are moving forward a little
bit so we might have a chance to move
forward a little bit there we are
same place I left him in the morning the
same because they were very well fed
they had no reason to go anywhere
look at that framing of the sticks there
and that youngster was very busy also
today
licking itself I doubt this is about
what they ate last night my feeling is
the condition they've been going through
offers kabocha kamesh which i think they
have recovered and come through very
well hello who are you
you're gonna recover should be fine but
it's true strange when you imagine how
cuts will get you no mange you know
including leopards and cheetahs but also
there's a possibility they would get it
even from the animals they've been down
under cloves you know even small animals
like buffaloes you know buffaloes will
have mange and when the Lions will hunt
buffaloes they could easily get you know
the mites from them as they're feeding
on the Buffaloes so let's see reposition
and give you a response
fantastic the way to go that's very good
and I'm equally excited and fabulet we
know when to stop okay
and you notice here they have young cups
thank you very much yeah that's the way
to go and I can also tell this one
should definitely make it if you see the
one on the neck you can see like dark
spots behind the e on the one licking
itself and that's a clear sign of range
I do not know how they looked maybe a
few months ago but depending on animal
normally the infection will start around
the ears the eyes and the neck and then
moving backwards that's where the
infection will start and I was saying
earlier players may not interact but if
one of them gets it definitely the rest
of them will you know gets infected
because the Lions are very touchy
they're very social cuts when they are
playing and then these mites will be
wandering off the bodies and then the
others will easily get it the big
question is always how they first get it
is that from you know some male lions
which they went wandering somewhere and
they picked it and when they are meeting
they bring it to them or as I said
earlier we have seen buffaloes also
getting affected by mange and the other
animals that also get affected like the
wildebeest also get affected by mange
also gurus apparently which have us of
gurus here get mange infection and
possibly when they hunt them they would
possibly get them as they feed them on
the skin and you know it's very easy for
the mites to get to a different or the
other type of animal and what the mites
will do they just come and using their
fangs dig burrows on the skin of the
animals and will make their will lay
eggs will see the lava there and the
nails
and they start affecting the whole
species but sometimes when I think of
mange as an infection this could be a
good balance for this animals so more
easily chance that they could you know
survive through the mange I would say
yes if what I gathered before that they
were in very bad shape a couple of
months ago and what I can see now I
would say these layers will make it and
they'll make it true if they were to die
I think they would have died long time
ago and as I just said mange has been
found out also as a stabilizer and if a
population like this is self-sustaining
this layer for example I see them making
it if they died they would have died way
back and we have sometimes seen mange as
you know away from Mother Nature to
balance the population of animals and
for this case maybe the Lions and this
whole pride is still surviving so
chances are yeah that one got at or near
there as much as trying to break a stick
I got a feeling this pride will make it
through
magic dragon wizard show Christmas is
the new Coahoma pride a larger than the
Styx pride I think the new comers I 11
turtle and the sticks are 13 so I think
or I believe this spread is much bigger
than day nakooma
well the new comers they look much
healthier and in good shape than this
ones Louis in earlier today in the
morning and where we the war we try to
go through there but we were not very
lucky to see them so you see that's very
touching for lions and I was saying
earlier if the one on the right has you
know the mites is just touching with the
other one as they are grooming there I
love grooming and reassembling the the
bones that's how the mites would get
from one and get into the other one
because there are times we don't have
the might see no barrowed on the skin
that could be just be on the far and
easily if they would feel some heat or
some black different species they would
easily move to the next one and get the
room and get a space to borrow and by so
doing they'll get to the other lioness
and affected schmitz you asking how far
have a lion pretty ever moved a few
things come in player Schmidt and I
would say number one is always if this
concern of the habitat I'm not sure that
rands trying to kill that stick as a
toothpick if there's a concern of them
getting any threat ownership from humans
they we are known to move very far away
and do not want take any chances but if
it's a question of prey the longest have
seen and this may be this could be in
East Africa could be about 30 odd miles
or 20 miles away from an area and that
I'm talking of a whole pride and that's
quite a distance for a protocol the male
lions will go maybe twice that distance
but the pride the females you know
because we're having the Cubs and being
very energy-efficient they may not go
far but I would say 30 miles or 20 or
mouth Schmidt they have you know known
to go this rides here which takes the
times you know we don't see them for
days
and we'll hear they've been seen in the
neighboring Game Reserve and when you
walk out to the exact location they are
it's always amount to that distance
sometimes even up to 30 miles away where
are you enjoying chewing the stick
solectron young children got teething
problems they'll always put stuff in
their mouth so just having fun it's
crushing the stick there they had a very
good meal last night of the water back
maybe - feels good for the teeth all
right we are now moving from some cuts
to some kind of reptile everyone I've
come down to chitchat - Adam we watching
Vladimir the crocodile I had to leave at
in Ghana he did not stop moving and he's
headed straight east and he's out on to
chat with planes a cheetah planes
already sorry sir he's moving back
towards where we found him quite a long
time ago with those two Impala kills and
maybe maybe he's moving in that
direction for a while maybe you'll be
back tomorrow who knows but a very
interesting that he's headed out that
far again you know we can put all sorts
of focus or you know thoughts on that
but and the ultimate is is that he's
design person his design leopard and
he'll do whatever he pleases as far as
other leopards will allow suppose now I
just wanted to clear something up from a
little bit earlier because there was a
question around what happens you know
with was tingoora mating with tandy now
I was thinking about a few different
things that at once there my answer
still stands around lipids and
inbreeding that that's I was answering
in a generic time but the fact of the
matter is
ting Ghana came from some way in the
Kruger nobody really knows who his
mother or his father was and so he's
he's not mating with his family with
Tandy
now he's had a few different Cubs with
Tandy and it's a very good mixture of
genes because of where he's come from so
there's not inbreeding they however was
you know Cubs of his iron through the
female and Sonny is always an
opportunity that he might might the same
and so on so that's what I was thinking
and excuse me for for insinuating that
they were family to start with I didn't
mean that I just got caught up in a few
different thought processes but let's
get back to the matter at hand
Wladimir back in his normal position I
would say that we found him flat out
with his very real crocodile smile
marika you say he looks like a sleeping
dragon and I think I think that's quite
fitting isn't it looks like he's
something out of Lord of the Rings very
much a smiling sleeping dragon there's
very big teeth they on the sides but
sleeping all the same there's a shut
tight Nancy I would not put the tip of
my big child in this water there's
enough crocodiles yet to snap off a
little loose toes and not I would
definitely not be going swimming in a
the crocodiles aside the hippo is I
think wouldn't be too happy about us
joining the fray as you see there
they're watching us even on the banks so
I think if you got out of the water and
went for a little swim there I think you
might find yourself in a bit of trouble
because there's enough hippos around
here and to possibly scrum you on your
way in and once you're in the water I
think you'll be snapped in half it's
quicker than you can say hippopotamus
there are lots of them around some of
them starting to come out of the water
they
little youngsters coming out of the
water well it seems like Rafiki Dave's
got the little Cubs playing two
youngsters coming out of the dam and the
youngsters here becoming more player
four than before so these Cubs have been
playing with sticks and crushing them
and trying to be more more by now as
it's cooling off going down picking
classes in their mouth getting some dry
sticks in their mouth showing them I'm
ready to give them some good feeling on
their gums and very interesting to see
the sticks with young cubs like this
haven't seen the newcomers yesterday so
one female that seem to have some
cycling marks see how playful this can
be here isn't that cute
lyrica I mean they females here you
asking how old are these females
I don't know for a fact all of how old
they are but they are fully grown when
the capsule gets a six or seven months
old but the females here are mature
because they are the mothers of these
cabs here but against the Cubs could be
anything six seven months but that's a
guess as I said early in the morning and
a Rick and another you're watching I
just saw these particular pride for the
first time today I can sell play if they
can beer how cute is that
come on bring a leg bring your paw
move forward okay what can we gonna play
now okay I'm tired but why is he like no
let's keep playing and the mothers get
excited when you see the Cubs playing
like this but perhaps mainly because
they need to build their muscles when
they play like that when time comes for
them maybe to start hunting they'll be
in good body shape the only thing I like
other animals they just play for short
time and the rest sorry what you must
say look Musti I agree with you this is
beyond cute yes and how playful Monsieur
they look at that hole their bill is up
there just listen in each other I hope
you enjoying all that moment they are
mercy come on bring your cheek and the
mother should just be you know happy
it's in the caps playing alright from
one cut to another spotted cut
we have got her again infrared is on
you've been left alone in the sighting
and she's been moving around positioning
herself nicely eating munching away at
the daycare still no sign of the
rebellious youngster uses those front
teeth to pluck fur and in the side
carnassial share of those teeth to cut
and to shear off hard pieces sinewy
pieces we as humans invented the steak
knife we are not true predators
omnivores our molars are designed for
grinding not for sheering canine that's
what in carnivores it's what makes
carnivores is that sharp
kinesio shear set of teeth on the
outside of the jaw
if you don't know what I'm talking about
let us know next time one of us are in
the tent and we'll show it to you on the
mini sculls that we have there you look
at a zebras skull and you'll see the
teeth are very flat so grazes have got
very flat sort of teeth browsers have
got very jagged molars she allows it to
break up the food to very small
particles the leaf material omnivores
would have a sort of a mixture between
and then the cane they're carnivores
have got very sharp cutting teeth the
canines are for fighting and for
subduing prey mr. public she's eaten the
most of it yet she is busy chewing I
think what she's doing she's not looking
for the skin really or the further she's
eating
most of the meat out of the body of the
animal and then it gets to sort of furry
places where she's trying to get some
sinew and maybe some meaty bits art and
so that's why she's getting quite
delicate in there they want to maximize
and get as much art as they can but they
don't necessarily want to eat the fur
there's no real benefit in the fur just
leads to them coughing it all up in a
furball but as much of the meat and and
possibly skin as they can get I quite
often leave a fair bit of skin behind
that's I will seal often find lipids and
their feed they'll pluck the fur out of
the skin and then eat around it eat
those patches
BJ Williams I have no idea I don't think
so I don't think that that happens I
mean there is a very very strangely
documented case of a leopard that killed
their baboon and then after killing the
baboon had found this baby baboon
attached to its body and then ended up
adopting the baboon for the evening
obviously the leopard didn't quite know
what to do with the baby baboon and it
ended up dying of exposure when they
read it to be cold nights I think when
you're really small baby you need to be
really tucked up in mums breasts to keep
walk when you're a baboon that is so it
didn't quite not to make of the little
baboon I don't know if it ended up
eating it afterwards but if he killed
its mother but a lion adopting a limpet
I don't think so I don't know maybe one
of the viewers out there seen something
like that before start something I've
ever heard of cursed FC said that a line
adopter leopard up in the Mara not so
long ago very interesting but no report
there of how long that lasted you know
might just be that little novelty
initially but as soon as they find out
it's there one of the archenemies since
they just kill it there's so much
instinct behind it but very interesting
behavior indeed I've never heard of that
before anyone else out there I know
there's a lot of yous who's been a fair
bit of time watching and researching if
you give us some insight into a lioness
adopting a leopard cub the successes of
that
and why would the leopard company
adopting did mum die that happens very
sad indeed it's still crunching away
well we still haven't seen Columba and
but David has got cubs playing around
one of the best thing to happen to the
cuts is when the temperatures go down
because that translates to more action
or to more movement or to them becoming
playful and especially these young cubs
here excuse me
and these two are not getting tired of
rustling each other and where so drinks
strengthening of their muscles
it's very typical for caps actually
mature at one point they know they'll be
living on the own of not necessary India
of course males they may have to move in
that one biting around here or the pole
is some things pulling there are some
kind of branch must be very playful one
I need to got a very good feeling when
to bite something in the mouth and I'm
sure you can tell now we have gone
through IR ideally the whole idea is
that we do not invade the animal space
we do not influence or affect the
behavior paula training any sport traits
from them it's something I just wish you
have some juice it's like you know when
I was a small boy how I used to chew
some sugarcane and I could put it big
sugarcane in my mouth and my mom was
like let's - before you get it out so
this one I don't think it's getting any
juice when it's up from that stick just
enjoying playing with it but it should
be careful doesn't get hurt cause - my
jump and then - must end up on the gum
having its best on the water while the
adults are not concerned yes Luke and
every one the FCR trying to imagine
David a shoe akin as a boy you know and
I could not let go and it could have a
sugar cane that was taller than me and
my mom was like don't waste it if you
can't finish it have a small piece you
know but these ones have a different
understanding of a sugar cane but I've
got a dry stick and they've got no SAP
on juice in it how play for they isn't
that funny
you didn't even think there's any
condition of you know mange in this
particular pride of lions here I mean it
doesn't seem to be affected them
affecting them in any way apart from you
know the condition that it gets on their
skins I do not think you know internally
mange is quite a concern until they get
you know very dehydrated when they get
hit so badly by it they'll get very
dehydrated and then Emma she ate it and
then maybe they died but normally you'll
see the skin condition not looking very
good but this ones look like they're
pulling through and internally I do not
think the mange would affect any
internal organ what will happen is out
guess for the Cubs like this because of
that condition they don't eat very well
and because of you know paying
malnourished they would easily be
abandoned or they may lack food and that
with me die I'm sure you know one of the
questions of lion cubs death is
abandonment or you know starving
I think starving should be number one
and then been abandoned by their mother
is number two so if they're getting very
weak because of mange mothers would move
on and just forget the money I've seen
once or twice you know and that cub in
the middle of nowhere and you look at it
carefully you notice you're suffering
from
I've been wondering if you know the the
coalition of Mayors around here are the
Birmingham's and their workers has
anybody been able to see them with that
condition because definitely out guess
unless otherwise they are the fathers of
his Cubs and it's you know coming into
contact direct contact with an infected
you know animal that you pick up the
mites and you get an infection I wonder
whether these cabs were sired by their
workers or the Birmingham's and anybody
have seen a Birmingham's
or their workers with any sign of mange
because you don't need you know a lot of
contracts thread contact as I said the
mites could be just rendering off on the
skin of the infected one and easily get
into another that's not infected and
they've been crisscrossing areas and
their territories have been overlapping
also with the new comers and homas have
not had mange and our imagine they have
laid in the same areas could there's
some animals for example the foxes if a
fox is infected and drank on a barrow
and then it moves in another fox comes
in and it's a raisin same barrel it
easily picks the mites and it also gets
men's it gets infected I'm trying to
imagine this Lions you know well this
particular pride within homers at one
point they have crisscrossed I just
shared some water pan or some bedding in
areas they lay they tend to use
particular areas for some reasons as
cats who do how the new comers have come
out of it could be big nice debate
a very good and just confound from Luke
the Birmingham just have mange and yes
that's a good very good well thank you
very much look for letting me know that
because yeah contact is one of the
easiest or is one of the best way to
infect me and from one you know one one
animal to another so any any contact of
a kind
is one way and we said Fox's evil is
somewhere down and Fox have a barrow and
you move on another Fox come in there
chances are the one that was there if it
had an infection of mange the new one
that comes in will definitely pick
either the eggs and most of the larva or
the nymph of the mites and get infected
thank you for letting me know that look
so the big ones no just waking up and
looking around the Cubs are not playing
as before those top look sometimes just
listen
Ruby how are you Anna that's a very good
question will the caps be hidden oh they
go with their dots for the hunt I would
say it will depend Ruby on what they'll
be going for if it's something big and
dangerous the Cubs will be hidden and
told to stay put
but save a small animal and not very far
from where the Slayers are they might
tag along but if it involve a bit of
chess the caps always stay hidden
somewhere until the mothers get the kill
sometimes on an open area they can twist
in an area or an advantage points for
example salmon mount on top of a log
where they conceive the parents hunting
and maybe learn a few skills here and
there these particular ones are really a
log grooming no she'll be trying to get
the mites out grooming or try to bite
and from my alliance let's find out what
Steve got with his spotted cut yes well
she's moved away from the remains of her
kill they're leaving what was left the
scraps she's moving at 60 yards or so to
where she will then clean herself still
no sign of her youngster she's moved at
least to where there's a decent enough
tree for her to quickly scurry up if
anything happens but it's my common
behavior in my opinion to see a leopard
once they're there
once they're finished especially if
there's not too much they've just a bit
of a smell to move off a safe distance
something cheetah do very often just in
case I mean it does come out of nowhere
there's a nice sort of branch fee to
jump on to she can clean herself with no
Derek sort of attraction whatever is
coming in
and no doubt what we saw this afternoon
when we found the other remains of their
data from yesterday where we found that
scat about 60 meters away it's possibly
just underneath a nice big tree it's
possibly exactly what she did as well
she moved off set under their tree ready
to jump up if need be and then obviously
at some point there was an ablution
stopped a very similar tactic taken
right here she cleans old blood of her
face any of you been licked by a
domestic cat I wonder what a lipids
tongue is like I've seen lions and
leopard licking the flesh off of an
animal she is hearing noise coming off
towards my left they all right infrared
well you know got no lights on Ruby yes
I'm sure she'd be able to go after a
scrub here or anything smaller like that
little noise in the left here I was
Tandy reacted to it I heard another
movement she hasn't reacted at all she
was looking so tell and we'll go to
something small most definitely I don't
know if she'll catch it though that
should definitely try and once she
catches it he won't quite have the
killer instinct behind her to to to end
its life and she is going in the other
direction are we gonna try catch up
honestly we get not going to be using
any lights see how we do
Charlie universe no I think perfectly
she's perfectly at that sort of stage we
watch shot them Ariel here Craig oh we
might lose you for a second folks
Rickson said he saw two lumber but I
didn't see her so we haven't seen her
yet Tandy's not behaving like she's here
okay so I'm gonna have to just use the
spots to see where she goes you might
lose over some aardvark burrows in and
around
so we didn't see to lumber this
afternoon is what I was saying
what is that something just behind that
bush but of a faulty spotlight yeah
Craig it okay that looks like her she
just had a little look back at me now
she's probably gonna go down and have a
drink
need to use the light otherwise I'm
going to fall into a hole I think we
should be good going this way the
aardvark seems to like digging on the
top of the hill it's very fine hooker
Morrie these days okay we're gonna see
if we can catch up with her she's
probably going down for a drink
hello hello hello
we are looking for night critters like
little chameleons here in the leaves
we haven't spotted any just yet but
we're gonna keep searching now in the
darkness hours they do not coming out
onto the bush wallow top trees not
really particularly where there's lots
of thorns often looking those kind of
bushes but we'll also be looking for any
of the little G nuts and I'm really
looking forward to seeing a civet so
that's what I'm hoping for in the next
little while while it's dark now I
haven't seen a civet in a long time but
I've seen a lot of their checks recently
so I'm just hoping that we see something
then you know buddy see them just
walking up the ride in front of you
let's have had most of my civet
sightings and I've also bumped into them
a couple of times on foot and we also
bumped into them it's you know they'll
just want darvid to show you just how
often mossad they'll go and sleep in a
just a big bunch of grass like that and
so when you're walking it's quite easy
to bump into them as I say I nearly
walked on top of a few of them and then
I jump out and it's it's not a it's not
a tiny animal so yeah it can make you
get quite a surprise and we do have
those heart attack birds which are the
Franklin and the spear fowl that jump
out next to you and I'll tell you your
heart skips a beat but wait for a civet
to jump out in front of you it has a
slightly better effect on the on the
nerves I would say you need a bit of a
cold shower after that but yeah just
looking for any of these not on animals
now Karan if you're a guest and you come
to one of these safari lodges here in
this area what happens is normally you
have your very early morning game drive
and and then an afternoon game drive so
you normally have three hours in the
morning
three hours in the afternoon and then
during the midday after your morning
drive yeah you normally have that option
of going for a bush walk as well but you
can also at some of the lodges you know
change your drive for a walk or and
that'd be in the morning or in the
afternoon because you know for me taking
a bush walk in the heat of the day is
not ideal so I normally suggest to my
guests to - especially if they're
staying you know for more than two
nights or so to forego one of the
morning drives and then we go out for a
walk especially you know as I say if
you've got a little bit more time
because if you've got a short amount of
time then obviously you do want to see
you know as much as possible in terms of
elephants lions leopards it's never
guaranteed but it is you know if you've
come all the way across around the world
you definitely do want to try and see
those animals especially if that's the
reason why you have come in the first
place but as I say it is the wild and it
can never be guaranteed but coming to a
place like the sabi sands and you can
almost guarantee seeing lipids that is
one of the real special things about
this area because there's lots of other
areas that you can see a lot of
elephants and lions and more so than
here but to guarantee or almost
guarantee seeing leopards in the amount
of them in such a small space as
habituated as these ones are to vehicles
and guards on foot it's this is I would
say probably one of the best places in
the world for that well you can tell me
if you now have a place better than the
sabi sands to do that and while old I'll
definitely listen now pani sure you're
asking you know around the numbers of
animals in other period of time what
does that take
Stian bookie yep cysteine mochi we don't
want to bother him because he's not a
daytime animal and if we shine the light
on him and just disturbing me then it
might changes his habits for no good
reason so penny sure I think you know
there might be more or less animals than
there were ten years ago but there's
always a fluctuation in accordance with
the resources and the weather and
climate of the particular period and I'm
just trying to think back ten years ago
what would we be there 2008 I was also
in the Kruger National Park area and I
can't say just off the top of my head
that I feel like there's any less
animals obviously as my thought process
is going I'm just saying that you know
we get some periods three four years of
a little bit more drier we get then
subsequently after that three four years
a little bit more weight so maybe
there's a little bit more resources
little bit of certain different plants
growing for a couple years and then they
die back a little bit so I think in
terms of just the general cycle of
things I think 910 years ago very
similar to the way it is now in the
Kruger National Park
obviously in general I would say in
South Africa yes these nice animals now
than they were ten years ago but in the
National Park per se I would say it's
just part of the natural cycle that's
going around okay so as I continue
looking on for any kind of night
creature
I believe Steve he was with an odd
creature what if he still is
no we could not keep up with the pace of
tündi she just goes straight through the
bushes we've got to go round so we're
going to try one more effort she kind of
had it sort of West ish from where she
was and it's likely she might be first
he's so maybe she's gonna go to
Gallagher watering hole we're gonna do a
little loop around there and see if
indeed that is what has transpired but
they would still know by the time we we
lost today there was still no sign of
sorry Craig of Columba and she didn't
make any calls any calls at all so maybe
after the lumbers sort of behavior of
stealing food and stuff mom is leaving
her away leaving her sort of still in a
distance she'll go back to her though no
doubt but the question before is how
independent does she but I think it's
pretty normal what's going on at the
moment you know they left but also the
youngster needs to be left alone from
time to time yeah some self-reflection
on stealing mums food but a quiet time
one would say but it's not uncommon for
her to have left her I mean she's been
doing that for some time she also gets
tired you know she doesn't want to move
as far as mum and you know what it's
like if you want to go on a hike
youngster doesn't want to go well the
youngsters gonna stay behind but Craig
oh you feel that the degrees drop as you
come down into this depression here all
of you out there know the laws of
gravity and cold essex whenever you go
these little sort of drainage
depressions it's a lot cooler down here
okay well before we lose the signal once
again with the gremlins David Guiteau
has still got his beautiful or should I
say mangy cats yeah I'm still with a
mangy cats here the sticks right and you
know we have always thought it smells
that's sleep and sleep and sleep you
know the males but also females given a
chance
they also sleep we already save you know
Lions literally 1520 hours in a day but
I think I would say even females sleep
more less the same why should they not
if they're very well fed and they have
enough to drink and bein
energy-efficient cars the only thing
they want to do is sleep so you can see
I left this you know cuts in the morning
sleeping found him sleeping and I saw
there
Stacy how are you today and you're
asking it seems a lot darker alia yes
because it's winter and this will go on
this month of June and the whole of July
and here we come to August we'll come to
summer and return just right earlier
than normal because it is winter if you
go to East Africa we still got enough
light at the moment 6 o'clock there's a
lot of light and our guests it will be
out on a game drive will not be using IR
you're right stacy is just because it's
winter and you know this large sleep and
they sleep a lot
I lives on the red you would see destroy
only word for today I do not know
whether you know what we call lions and
so I head out guess that one you know
and we call them Simba as I am be a
symbol
so because I'm wishing this life as well
and I want to hope you know the mange
will be out of them the infection will
go very soon when things are good in
Swahili we say Sawa Sawa and that is
Sawa Sawa
so I so on a lady you want for today of
course I would guess you know what Simba
is it's like ok ok all is good and you
see Sawa Sawa
so you're 1 + up unlike Hakuna Matata so
I want you now to go to a different
level and you start saying sour sour
from today so we hopefully we see the
spread of lions maybe the next one 2
months from now the infection of the men
will be gone and we say this lions or
these Simba's ah
sour sour so continue licking itself and
the rest you can see paws up and in
dreamland enjoying sleep life is good
I'm fed I have enough to drink why do I
have to worry but at one point I'm sure
come maybe 10 o'clock I'm sure they
might move to a different area because
for instance where they were last night
is not where I found them this morning
this lovely and how exciting Ching gonna
the bell you know Tandi the queen of
this area with her princess you know and
now with stick lives what a day I'm
thinking at this time now I go and I get
my sugar cane just like that lion come
cap was doing putting the stick in the
mouth I'm going out to look for my sugar
cane and remind myself how I used to do
when I was a small boy it has been a
fantastic day
and we thank all of you for having join
us remember we'll be with you tomorrow
zero 6:30 thank you and from all of us
good bye